- How can you tastefully send a dick pic?
- You just get lazy with the dick pic?
- She was, she, I'm being honest.
- Hi, my name is Morgan.
I work in the television industry.
I love to go on runs in my free time,
and I also love to travel.
What I'm hoping to get out of today
is to just meet a nice guy that hopefully
we can go on a date with.
We'll see.
(rock music)
I'm looking for a guy that's nice,
funny, has good family values,
and is tall, because I'm super tall.
(bell dings)
I'm a little nervous.
- Let the games begin.
- I'm gonna send a greeting at first.
- Oh, she just texted all of us.
- "Hi, guys.
My name is Morgan."
- Morgan.
- Now I, like, notice I say hey, hi?
- Do we emoji back?
- How do you do it?
- She gave us the emoji.
- Uh.
- Still waiting.
- She didn't capitalize her own name.
Huh.
- "Hello, I'm Leo."
- This is my favorite emoji.
- He did the nerd emoji.
Oh gee.
- That's my go-to.
- Yeah.
- "Hey Morgan. I'm Shane."
- Ah, no emoji.
Playing coy, I like that.
- No emoji.
Judging you.
- Keep it simple.
- "Hello there Morgan, my name is Ben."
Chicken.
(chicken clucking)
(laughs)
- The rooster is the best emoji.
- Classic.
It's iconic.
- It's so dumb lookin'.
(upbeat music)
- How many...
- "Dating apps do you
currently have on your phone?"
- Oh boy.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh man.
- Why is it taking so long?
Are they, like, counting?
- I'd never want to admit
that I'm even on those things.
- Is it bad if I don't?
Zero dating apps.
- "Zero dating apps.
Not your average millennial."
Respect.
- Dot, dot, dot, two.
- "Dot, dot, dot, two?"
Like, does that mean,
like, I'm only thinking
of two right now, like,
off the top of my head,
or, like, I had multiple
and then I deleted them?
- I have two, but I would
delete them for you.
- Oh, you're gonna shoot a line now.
Oh wow.
- "But I would delete them for you, baby."
- And one just wrote in,
"Ooo, the kitchen is hot."
(laughs)
- I have no idea, like, we weren't, okay.
We're gonna ask them what
their go-to pick up line is.
- Pick up lines.
- Yeah, how do you slide into DMs?
- Suitor 2 is, "You up?"
- Oh, okay.
(laughs)
- You up?
- Like, am I up, like, am I awake?
- That is a ballsy move, honestly.
- Hello, I am very wealthy and handsome.
- That works.
(laughs)
- I mean, wealthy is a relative term.
- One says, "Hey, what's up."
- Yours is, hey, what's
up with just the emoji?
(laughs)
- I think he could do better.
- Pick up lines are just not my thing.
- It's better than mine.
- Okay, so far I'm leaning towards three,
and not because he's wealthy and handsome,
just because, well, part of the reason.
Um, I'm very traditional.
I like when a guy pays on the first date.
- "Would you let the woman
pay on the first date?"
- Heck yeah, would I let her?
Which is not my, yeah, of course.
- "Absolutely.
Go for it girl."
Uh, okay.
- By all means, pay for dinner.
- I really am not feeling one.
- I think we're doing pretty well here.
- At all.
- Only the second round of drinks,
because the first one is on me.
- Okay, so we're, like,
splitting the check.
- If I like this girl...
- "If I like this girl and it
was going well, I would not.
If she was hard to stand,
we're splitting it."
- Fair enough.
- I think that's fair.
- That's fair.
- Where's the taco emoji?
- Oh, "We're having a taco party.
What do you put in your taco?"
- I mean, like, let's get real.
It's kind of sexual,
but it's a way to say,
like, who's vegan, who's vegetarian.
- I knew she was gonna bring up tacos.
(laughs)
I don't know how I knew this.
- Suitor 3 said tacos are tight.
I freaking love them.
Suitor 2 said great
question, I love tacos.
- We should all start
saying the exact same thing.
- We just, like, obsess
over the taco thing.
- And then Suitor 1 said
I put a taco in my taco.
(laughs)
- Say, wait, you've got tacos?
Where? Where?
(squeaking)
- They're just saying I love tacos.
- I'm having too much fun with myself.
- So apparently these,
they all like tacos.
- "Which cereal describes you and why?"
- Frosted flakes, 'cause I'm great.
- "I'm great."
- I'm great!
- What are you putting?
- I'm saying--
- That's great man, that's pretty great.
- And then, "Fruity
pebbles 'cause love wins."
- 'Cause love wins.
because I'm sweet like honey (chuckles)
and I got a bunch of love or something."
- This is a bad answer.
- And now let's, let's get serious again.
I'm gonna ask for what are
these guys looking for.
- What are you looking for in a girl.
- Oh, shoot.
- It's a big question, Morgan.
- It goes silence in the room, like.
- Huh.
- So many things.
- Number three, a sense of humor,
intelligence, easy to talk to, cute,
kind, and maybe rides a motorcycle."
(laughs)
- You're covering all the bases right now.
- I should throw a psycho thing in there.
Good feet.
- I'm looking for a sense of humor, too.
Motorcycle, I hate motorcycles.
Three definitely knows what he wants.
- Love a girl who's, uh,
can dabble in some sports.
- "I love a girl who is athletic."
That's definitely me.
I do love to run, and I love
a good outdoor activity.
- Yeah, man.
This is hard.
- Yeah, number one has been the slowest.
- You guys are covering
all the bases right now.
Like, how am I supposed to follow up?
- Okay, so he just wrote in,
"Likes dogs.
Likes to eat.
She's gotta be weird."
She's gotta be weird, like
what do you mean weird?
- Type of girl who goes to a museum
but also shotguns a beer.
- Shotguns a beer.
Okay.
- If she can shotgun a beer..
- That's it right there.
- What if she shotgun a beer at a museum?
- Oh.
- I wanna find out how
tall these guys are,
but I'm trying to think of a creative way
to ask that without
just being straight up.
- What sports do you play?
- Well, boys, what sports do you play?
- Golf.
Play a lot of golf.
- I play a lot of golf.
I'm guessing that he's 5'9", 5'10".
- Alright.
- Nah, I'm not gonna put anything.
- I got a solid answer.
I said, I eat out often,
and that requires walking
to the restaurant, if that counts.
- "If that counts."
No.
- Well, hey.
That's exercise.
- Three wrote, I'm sorry.
"I used to play basketball,
but the only sport
I do now is surf."
I'm into that.
Three seems like he's a jokester.
Kinda quick and sarcastic, which I like.
Two seems like he's traditional,
or a bit more old fashioned.
Probably a little of a quieter guy.
Number one just seems boring.
So these are my last questions,
so I'm gonna get a little
bit more intense over here.
Have you ever sent
a dick, sick?
I hate when it, like, dick.
Have you ever sent a sick pic.
(laughs)
- Wow.
- Woah.
- So we just turned it up a notch here.
- Imagine if a guy, like, has an album.
(laughs)
- Gross.
- I just can't.
- That's a relevant topic.
- Like, what about like, we
should call it penis portrait.
- Okay, Suitor 1.
"No, but I'm open minded."
- I could be swayed.
- Suitor 2.
(scoffs)
"I don't think we're there
in our relationship to
discuss that, Morgan."
(laughs)
- That is a very private question.
- Then say I don't think we're there yet.
- Suitor 2's shy.
- Suitor 3 probably has, like, an album.
- I have, but in the privacy.
- "In the privacy of a relationship,
and only when they asked
me, and tastefully done."
How can you tastefully send a dick pic?
- You just get lazy with the dick pic?
- She was, I'm being honest.
- Using emojis, describe our first date.
- I've always wanted to
tell a story with emojis.
- I'm just gonna do the 100 emoji.
- So, Suitor 3 wrote a hundred,
a hundred, a hundred emoji,
and then he wrote the monkey with the
crossed out, and then he wrote music,
chicken, TM, and love.
- That's a thinker.
(laughs)
- It certainly is.
- For me this, it looks like
our date's going really well,
then we're gonna get really
close and do something,
and then we're gonna go to a concert,
eat chicken, and fall in love.
(laughs)
Okay.
- You know, you got the
hold your hands emoji.
- It's roses.
- And you know, you
gotta bust out flowers.
I'm a classy type of guy.
- Champagne.
- Pops some bottles.
- A turkey stick.
- Some dinner, you know, turkey leg, soup.
- Dancing.
- Dinner and dancing, that's
where the lightning happens.
- Lightning.
- 'Cause that's where I'm at my best.
- He's confident.
- Zap.
- This guy's, like, pretty creative.
I'm kinda surprised at one.
Suitor 2 wrote, money, kiss, dancing,
martinis, taco, ice cream, singing.
- You got a little martini, a taco,
maybe go out for ice cream after.
- Mic drop.
Kinda leaning toward Suitor 2,
'cause I like to dance, and
I like to drink martinis.
So for my last question.
Now...
- "Now that you all know each other,
why should I pick you
over the last two guys?"
(laughs)
- Listen up, Morgan.
- That's a deal breaker.
- "Listen up, Morgan."
See, three knows what he wants.
- These two boys are chumps.
- They're all turning on each other.
- Oh, and P-U, they also smell.
- Suitor 2, I'm taller.
- Wait, how tall are you?
- 6'2".
- I'm 6'3" baby!
(laughs)
- Fuck, that doesn't work.
- Suitor 3, "I also love my mom,
and these two have been
talking shit about theirs."
(laughs)
- Like, that's gotta be the deal breaker.
- Incessantly.
Sorry, guys.
- I'm going with, they're
actually all dope.
- Oh, see that's a good route.
- You can't lose.
- "They're actually dope.
I like them all.
You really can't lose either way."
I don't like that.
I like a guy that, like,
stands up for what he wants.
- Compassion.
Chicks dig it.
So I guess that's it.
Now we find out.
- One doesn't seem like
he knows what he wants.
You know, she's just gonna go with Leo.
- You know, I feel like
she's gonna go with me, too.
- With his--
- So it's between 2 or 3.
Three is definitely a confident guy
that knows what he wants,
but I feel like three
is a little bit shorter.
I feel like 2 is taller,
which is kinda drawing
me more towards 2.
I choose, dot, dot, dot.
(suspenseful music)
- So, is this what it's
like to be on the Bachelor?
Man, just week after week with the roses.
- I don't know if I could do it.
- Oh.
- I'm gonna have to go with 3.
- Three! Gosh.
- You have bad taste.
- Darn it.
- Three, you have bad taste.
(laughs)
- Hi.
- Hi, Leo.
- Nice to meet you.
- I should have put more thought into it
and wasn't so nonchalant with my answers.
Well, actually, I guess
that worked for Ben, so.
- Hi.
- There's no real way to prepare.
It just wasn't my day.
- Oh, hey.
- Hey.
(laughs)
- Baby, I got a date, I got tacos comin'.
I'm very glad you chose me.
I was not expecting that, and
I wish I had dressed better.
- Yeah, I thought you were rich.
- The lesson you should learn from me
is to never take yourself too seriously.
That was a lie.
- That's, that's okay.
- You were much better
with text messaging.
(laughs)
(upbeat music)